All
right. So, today uh we're going to begin
our discussion of Dynamo. Um or we're
going to continue really our discussion
of Dynamo. For today's class, I asked
you to read the Dynamo paper. And last
time, uh I talked a little bit about um
how this paper was important and
influential. Uh so, back in the olden
days, the assumption was that of course
you would want to have strong
consistency in your replicated storage
system. And that was considered
practically an answered question. Then
Amazon came along uh and they they came
out with this paper uh which which said
we don't care about strong consistency.
We're going to prioritize availability
instead. Now I have to say I don't
personally love the way that this paper
is written. I think some parts of it
just aren't well written and there's a
big chunk of text repeated in the first
paragraph. Uh something that should have
been caught in a copy editing pass. Uh
which is annoying, right? Like come on.
If you're going to write one of the most
influential distributed systems papers
of this millennium, at least have the
decency to take a copy editing pass over
it first. Um, but it's a great paper to
read in terms of how it connects with
this class and it touches on a whole lot
of the concepts that we've already
discussed. Um, so now that you've
actually read the paper hopefully, um,
what are some of the concepts that we've
talked about so far in this class that
play some sort of role in Dynamo?
Sorry about that. Had to adjust my
headphones. All right. Vector clocks are
mentioned in there. Good replication.
Sure. Of course.
Uh,
these are good ones. What else?
Uh, Byzantine faults. Yeah. So,
Byzantine faults are mentioned uh but
only in the context of saying they're
not going to worry too much about
Byzantine faults. Um, availability
versus consistency, right? That's this
is a big one. Um, this is what we talked
about before. Um,
uh, a consensus model. Uh, probably what
you mean there is consistency model.
Tornadoes, the notion of a tornado
hitting the data center. Yeah. All
right. So, so, uh, availability versus
consistency is is probably the the high
order bit. Um, so this is a big one. So,
so how did we define availability?
Our our sort of first cut definition of
it was all requests receive a response.
Um, but we could edit that to mean say
all requests receive a meaningful
response
instead of just a response like I don't
know or I'm not going to tell you. Um,
and we might even want to put some time
limit in there.
Although I hesitate to specify any
particular time limit. Um so uh um
if somebody wants to make an update, put
something in a shopping cart, let's say,
then the principle of Dynamo is go ahead
and let them do it no matter what.
Network partition, no problem. You don't
wait around to get acknowledgements from
all the replicas and if it means that
there's some data loss sometimes then so
be it. Uh because a availability is what
we want to prioritize.
So network partitions are another big
one. Um so we we talked about network
partitions last time. Um so um so
somebody remind me what a network
partition is.
some replicas can't communicate. Right?
So machines in some part of a network
are unable to reach machines in another
part.
So network partitions are temporary and
they're unintentional. So this is as
opposed to an a a
uh explicit decision to choose to not
allow two machines to communicate. This
is something that's temporary and
unintentional.
What else? What other concepts came up
in this paper
that haven't been mentioned yet?
What did we talk about last time?
Starts with E.
eventual consistency. Yeah.
So, eventual consistency uh is an old
idea.
Uh it's been around since uh at least
the 90s. Um but uh it sort of had a
resurgence uh as a result of Amazon and
and or as a result of Dynamo and systems
like Dynamo uh in in the mid 2000s. So
this goes along with high availability
and network partitions right if you want
to offer high availability and you want
to offer uh partition tolerance
um then you have to relax your
consistency requirements. Now, as we
talked about last time, this property of
eventual consistency fundamentally
belongs in a different category than
those other consistency models that we
talked about. Um, so we talked about
strong consistency and causal
consistency and FIFO consistency. I
wouldn't try to put eventual consistency
uh in this same hierarchy. Um, I'm a
little bit of a hypocrite when I say
this because that there are some
contexts where I do try to fit it into
that hierarchy, um, including papers
I've written. But, um, but I'm I'm I'm
telling you, uh, I think that it really
belongs in a different category because
all of those other consistency models
are safety properties that rule out
certain anomalous executions. And
eventual consistency, on the other hand,
is a livveness property.
It's hard to say exactly what kind of
safety property we get from Dynamo in
terms of consistency. Um, let me write
down a definition for this here. Um uh
if updates stop arriving, replicas
eventually come to agree.
So I don't know what safety property we
get from Dynamo. uh we talked last time
about strong convergence right uh which
is the property that if two replicas
have gotten the same set of updates then
uh their states will agree even if those
updates arrived in different orders. So
that's a safety property and that's a
part of what's known as strong eventual
consistency which we talked about last
time which has both a safety component
and aliveness component.
uh but I don't think Dynamo actually
claims to offer strong convergence in
general and the paper certainly doesn't
mention this idea of strong eventual
consistency. Uh that was an idea that
popped up a few years later.
Um so the by the way Amazon didn't
invent this concept. Um so I believe the
term was coined by uh a guy named Doug
Terry and his colleagues uh to describe
a system that they built uh called Bayou
in the '9s. Uh but Amazon really
popularized it to the point where now a
lot of people think that Amazon invented
this term eventual consistency. Uh and a
lot of people cite uh Warner Vogel's uh
who wrote a an article in 2008 called
eventually consistent. A lot of people
cite that article if they need a
citation for this term eventual
consistency. Uh I've been guilty of this
myself. Uh so uh public service
announcement. If you're going to site
somebody for eventual consistency, uh,
don't cite the 2008 paper by Warner
Vogals. Um, cite the older work by Doug
Terry. Um, okay. So, what else is in
this paper that we've already discussed?
Vector clocks were mentioned. Um, vector
clocks.
So, how does how does Dynamo use vector
clocks?
keep track of virgin history. Yeah. To
give a logical time stamp to events. So
when replicas differ, vector clocks are
the first line of defense for conflict
resolution. and Dynamo will try to use
vector clocks to resolve conflicts. Um,
but as we've discussed many times,
vector clocks can't resolve all
conflicts because some events are
causally independent or concurrent. Um,
so what does Dynamo do then uh when
vector clocks aren't enough?
Right. Yeah. So it either it there are
two options and and both of those were
just mentioned in chat. Um timestamps or
leave it to the client. Right. So it
Dynamo either lets the client do the
conflict resolution with their own
conflict resolution mechanism that the
client provides or it uses last right
wins. So it uses timestamps.
So we talked a tiny bit about this
application specific conflict resolution
thing last time and the idea is that
because the application developer
presumably knows something about the
data that they're storing
and what kind of conflict resolution
makes sense to do on that data, then
they can implement their own conflict
resolution mechanism that makes sense.
Um
so for example uh in the paper
there was we talked about resolving
conflicts between shopping carts by
taking their union
and then taking uh and then taking the
union on the client side to get the the
final shopping cart. Um by the way um
why did they pick set union and not set
intersection?
So, we talked about this a little bit
last time, like what if one replica
thinks that there's a pair of pants in
the shopping cart and the other one
thinks that there's a book in the
shopping cart. Um, uh, why why is it
that you choose to take union on the
client side and not not intersection to
sell more product? That's the joke that
I made in this class last year. Um, so
if you picked set intersection, right,
you might lose some additions to the
cart, right? Let's say one replica know
knows about both the book and the pants
that I've added and what and the other
replica only knows about the book. If I
then take set intersection
uh on the client side, then if I if I
take uh the intersection
of of
book and pants
and book,
then the intersection of those two sets
is just the set containing the book.
Whereas if I were take to take the union
of those two sets, I would get the book
and the pants. So either way, you might
have a problem, right? You might make a
mistake. If you picked set intersection,
then you might lose some additions to
somebody's shopping cart that had only
made it to one replica.
But if you picked set union, then you
could also make a mistake because you
might accidentally read some deleted
items. Let's say that one client had
added the book and the pants. Let's say
the other other one um uh looked at that
shopping cart uh had received the the
whole shopping cart and then said, "Oh,
you know what? I don't want the pants
after all." Um but then if you were to
look at the two replicas and then uh
take the union of those, then that
deleted item would get readded to the
cart. Um, so Amazon apparently decided
that readding deleted items is better
than losing added items.
So we'll talk later on about mechanisms
to handle deletion. Uh, deletion is
often very hard to deal with in
distributed systems. Um, of course,
Dynamo gets used for all kinds of things
other than shopping carts. So set union
doesn't always make the most sense to
do. So that's why Dynamo allows you to
provide your own conflict resolution
mechanism. If you don't provide one,
then fine, they'll just use last right
wins in that case.
Questions about that.
Okay, so here's a question for you all.
Let's just think about this case of
shopping carts. So with shopping carts,
we have this property that writes
commute with each other and so we don't
care about the order in which they
arrive. Um
what is what does commutivity mean by
the way? So
a binary operation is commutative if
changing the order of the operand
doesn't change the result. So for
example, addition is commutative, right?
So a plus b equals b plus a. So what do
we mean by commutative when we're
talking about uh about rights? So when I
say rights commute with each other, I'm
sort of abusing terminology, right?
Because I'm because I'm no longer
talking about a a binary arithmetic
operation. Uh but it's the same basic
idea that the order of the rights
doesn't affect the result. So in other
words, if you're treating your shopping
cart as a set and you add book and then
pants, you'll have the same result as if
you added pants and then book. That's
what I mean. Um that's what I mean by
communivity uh u in in this context. Um
the order of rights doesn't matter.
Uh so here's my question.
With shopping carts, we have this this
nice commutativity of rights. Um and
that by itself um is enough to give us
strong convergence, right? But the paper
also talks about vector clocks.
So why do we also need vector clocks?
Because normally vector clocks would be
for enforcing causal consistency or
causal delivery, right? Or some sort of
causal causality related property. Um
but they didn't promise causal
consistency in this paper.
So why have vector clocks? If you're
doing shopping carts, what do you still
need vector clocks for?
What do you think?
Okay. Okay. Somebody mentioned keep
track of who put what in the cart first.
But does it really matter who put what
in the cart first? And if if it if it
doesn't matter. Okay. So there's a
there's a good point here. How are
shopping cart operations commutative if
you can do deletions? Right. Yeah. So I
think that the use of vector clocks in
Dynamo is to try to minimize these sort
of deletion anomalies that can occur. So
the vector clocks are able to rule out
most, although not all, deletion
anomalies.
You're still occasionally going to have
a deletion anomaly, and they say that
they're okay with that.
All right.
So every now and then you're going to
get into this sort of situation where
replicas disagree
and maybe even one of them has an
updates that that that is causally later
than the other according to their vector
clocks or maybe they disagree because of
concurrent updates that aren't
resolvable using vector clocks whatever
but one way or another replicas
disagree.
Well, okay. So, one of the challenges
here is even finding out that replicas
disagree in the first place. Um because
going back to that example that we've
sketched out before
where you have two clients and two
replicas
and you have differing rights.
We can see from looking at these picture
at this picture that replica one and
replica 2 disagree. um but they don't
know that they disagree. So job one,
right, is to even notice that they
disagree. And then after that, they
still have to figure out how to resolve
the conflict.
So even finding out that replicas
disagree with one another in the first
place is hard. So if we're drawing
Lampport diagrams like this, we have a
sort of God's eye view of the whole
situation. Uh which is a great luxury,
right? If you're actually trying to
build and debug distributed systems, um,
as you know, you don't have this lovely
god's eye picture. We can see that
there's disagreement, but the replicas
can't. So, this replica, which thinks X
is three right now, has no way of
knowing that somebody else thinks X is
four.
So, Dynamo
has a couple of mechanisms in place to
allow the system to try to find out
about and resolve such conflicts.
So, one of those mechanisms is what's
known as anti-entropy.
Can somebody who recalls what this was
in the paper uh tell me what it means?
Yeah. So, anti- anti- entropy is a is a
protocol that you can use to try to keep
replicas consistent. How does it work in
Dynamo? In Dynamo, the way it works is
that once per second, every node
randomly picks another node and contacts
it and finds out what its state is.
Actually, to be very clear, there there
are two different things being discussed
here. Um, when the paper talks about
anti-entropy,
it's talking about resolving conflicts
in replica state. um meaning the actual
key value pairs being stored because
Dynamo is a key value store right
so anti-entropy
is for resolving conflicts
in replica state
and replicas
randomly contact
other replicas
at a regular interval
to find out their state.
So this is distinct from something else
that the paper talks about. Um the paper
also talks about something called
gossip.
Uh which is related but different. Uh
when the paper talks about gossip uh
it's talking about uh it's also talking
about communication between replicas. Um
but it's not about uh replica state in
terms of the actual key value pairs
being being stored.
Does anybody remember what gossip is
used for in this paper?
Remember when we talked about um
different problems that all amount to to
consensus problems? Uh one of the
problems that we talked about was the
group membership problem. So this had to
do with that.
So what does Dynamo use gossip for?
looking at other nodes routing tables.
Yeah. So in other words, it wants to
know
what nodes are actually participating in
the system and what does it what does it
think the other nodes what what do the
other nodes think the other nodes are
right so this is another kind of state
that has to be kept consistent between
replicates in addition to the actual
data being stored these key value stored
these key value pairs they have to keep
track of what nodes exist right um and
in Dynamo This is done via gossip.
So gossip is for
resolving conflicts
uh
in the view of membership.
So two different mechanisms, but they're
for resolving conflicts in different
kind of different kinds of state, right?
Anti-entropy is for resolving conflicts
in key value pairs. Gossip is for
resolving conflicts in what do the other
replicas think uh the current uh set of
nodes are that are up. Um so that's what
gossip does. So a node contacts another
node to say hey what's your view of
who's up and running right now and
gradually they all figure it out.
So membership here means who is up and
running.
So what's interesting about this paper
um is that they say that they actually
used to have a mechanism that maintained
a globally consistent view um but they
figured out that they didn't need it. Um
and so they do gossip instead and that
ends up being good enough. So I I find
this to be interesting. They used to
have this this mechanism for maintaining
a globally consistent view. Maybe they
had some centralized configuration
server that everybody would talk to to
find out what the current view was and
that probably ended up being some kind
of a bottleneck. And so they figured out
uh that they didn't need that. So they
ended up using this this gossip
mechanism instead. And um and so just
like
uh the the current view of the data is
eventually consistent in Dynamo um the
current view of membership is also
eventually consistent in D in Dynamo and
that turned out to be good enough for
their needs.
Um so Dynamo has these different
mechanisms in place for resolving
conflicts in application state. So let
me say here application
application state meaning the actual key
value pairs being stored and conflicts
in in group membership state meaning a
node's view of what other replicas are
up and running and these mechanisms are
called anti-entropy and gossip
respectively.
So this happens to be the way that this
paper uses these terms. Uh sometimes
you'll see people use these terms as
synonyms and anti-thropy is just a fancy
word for gossip. Uh but in the context
of this particular paper they happen to
mean different things.
Okay. So gossip and anti-entropy are
both for resolving conflicts in some
kind of state. Um but here's a question
for you. Practically speaking,
how are these two problems different?
How is resolving conflicts in
application state different from
resolving conflicts in group membership
state in terms of practical
implementation concerns?
So these are conceptually very similar,
right?
Um,
and
I really the question that I'm asking
has to do with the kind the the amount
of state that's being sent between
replicas. So
the states like think about what what
information we have to send back and for
in in in the case of these two
situations. So with gossip, if you ask
somebody else, hey, what replicas are
up, right?
It's a pretty small amount of data that
has to be sent back.
But if you ask some replica, what are
all the key value pairs that you have?
The state, the amount of state that has
to be sent back is much, much larger.
So with group membership, you really
just have this kind of small number of
nodes. you have this this set or list of
of some relatively small number of
nodes. But for application data,
application state, you could have a lot
of key value pairs.
So given that the states are so large,
this right here, find out their state.
This could be pretty hard to do. It
isn't going to be feasible for replicas
to st send their complete state to each
other all the time once per second. That
would end up being pretty expensive and
and you would flood your network uh with
just these anti-enthropy messages.
So what does Dynamo do instead? Instead
of sending the complete state to other
replicas all the time, what do they do
to minimize the cost of data transfer
for this anti-enthropy process,
right? They use something called Merkel
trees.
also
known as hash trees.
So a merkele tree looks something like
this.
So let's say you have some pieces of
data. I'll draw it from the bottom up.
So I'll call them one two three and
four.
So these are just pieces of data any
data. Um in our case they they would be
key value pairs. Um but Merkel trees
don't uh require this to be about key
value pairs. You could use any kind of
data here. So these are just pieces of
data.
So with the leaves of the tree,
you have hashes of each chunk of data.
And then for the non-leaf nodes,
every node is going to store the hash of
its children.
So in this case you would do something
to concatenate or otherwise put together
these two hashes and then take the hash
of that
And similarly here.
So let's call this whole thing A and
call this whole thing B.
And then
The parent of these would be
the hash
of A and B concatenated or otherwise put
together.
Then that's the root.
So at the leaves of the tree you have
hashes of each chunk of data and these
would be you know maybe sets of key
value pairs or whatever else.
And then at the non-leaf nodes, each
node is going to store the hash of its
children.
This one happens to be a binary tree. So
non-leaf nodes have two children. And
they might, for instance, concatenate
their children's hash values and then
take the hash of that and so on up to
the root.
What is the purpose of doing this?
Yeah. So the problem that we're trying
to solve is this cost of data transfer
problem, right? We don't want to have to
send our entire state over to another
replica, right? So if we have two
replicas
each storing lots of key value pairs and
let's say that they differ in the value
of just one key, right? It would be
really really expensive to have to send
the entire state from one replica to the
other to compare it, especially since
there's just only this one point of
disagreement. So if you had this, let's
say
replica one
and replica 2.
So let's say replica one had like x = 3,
y = 4,
z = 5,
q = 7.
And let's say replica 2 had almost
exactly the same data but differed in
one place. So let's say
But how are you going to quickly find
out that there's only this one point of
disagreement? Um well, that's where you
can use Merkel trees. Um so in this
case,
say these are our data items.
So you take the hash of each of those.
So you'd have.
So I'm going to put a a tick mark here
to show that this one is different.
So when you combine these two
you get this single hash value.
And so these are going to be the same,
but these are going to be different.
and so the root of course is going to be
different because one of the children is
different.
So uh if this is a and b and this is a
prime
and b
So this thing the root
is the thing that gets sent around from
replica to replica at first. So replica
1 wants to know what replica 2's state
is. Replica 2 can send over this hash
value to replica 1,
which is just one number, right? As
opposed to having to send all this data,
replica 1 can look at it and see, oh,
that hash value is different from mine.
Okay, I see that it's different. So, I
know now that our replicas differ in at
least one key value pair.
Okay, now send me your children. So,
then replica 2 can send over these two
children.
Replica one will look at those, compare
it to its own children. It'll see that
this one is the same, right? Its value
for this uh uh this child is the same.
And it'll see that this one is
different. At that point, it knows that
everything
under this branch of the tree is going
to agree. So, it doesn't have to worry
about that anymore. It's now ruled out
half of the key value pairs as key value
pairs that it doesn't have to worry
about synchronizing with replica 2
because it knows that they already
agree. It now knows that the
disagreement is going to be somewhere in
this branch. So it's cut down the size
of of the search space by half. So then
it can dig further down and and compare
the children there.
So then it'll see that this hash value
differs um for this particular one.
And then finally at that point uh it can
see that those two differ and again it's
just comparing numbers right. Um so now
it can see that they differ and now it
says okay send me your value for key Y.
And to to make it even more clear why
this is useful uh in Dynamo or in many
key value stores these keys uh or the
values that are stored these keys
they're not necessarily just numbers
like five right they could be
arbitrarily large objects so having to
actually send over the the value
associated with the key even just one
key could be somewhat expensive right uh
depending on the what's actually being
stored in the key value store so it
could be somewhat expensive to send over
that whole object compared with the cost
of having to send over uh one little old
say 32-bit hash value. So
you save a lot of bandwidth uh by
comparing hashes and only having to send
over the data for uh for for uh values
that actually differ.
So Merkel trees are this mechanism for
finding out what quickly finding out
where the point of disagreement is
between these replicas. Um so in this
case only this one data item is
different on these two replicas and so
um the so the parent will be different
and then the parent of that will be
different and finally the root will be
different. So to compare their state you
be you can begin by comparing the root.
If it's the same, great. Um, you then
know that all the underlying data is the
same. If not, then you have to compare
the two children. Um, and in this case,
child A will differ while child B will
agree. So, you can then focus in on A,
look at its children. Then figure out
that it's this particular item that
differs. And we figured that out by just
sending a few small hashes over the
network instead of lots of data.
So a question in chat just now was,
well, what if there's more than one hash
that's different between each of the
replicas? Sure thing. Yeah, that could
happen. Yeah. So Merkel trees only help,
right? They they they help in the case
where there's there's only a small
difference between these replicas,
right? So if if a lot of keys differed,
um then both of these children uh might
uh might differ uh from from the
corresponding children on the other
side. and all these children might
differ as well. So in the worst case you
do end up in the situation where you
have to send over all the data, right?
Um but you have to do that anyway,
right? So
Merkel trees are especially useful in
the situation where you expect the
replicas to be mostly caught up with one
another
and uh they're handy anytime that you
need to compare large data sets. So
often you'll hear Merkel trees discussed
in a in a context of um of of data
analysis uh and comparing large data
sets. They're they're especially useful
if you need to do so over a network,
right?
Um
so they're used in all kinds of systems,
not just in key value stores. Um you'll
often hear them discussed uh for
properties of of verification, right?
Like if somebody has some data uh
somebody else has some data and you want
to ensure that they got the right data
right then you can uh you can compute
this hash value u by taking hashes of
individual pieces of data and then the
parents of those and so on uh until you
get this uh this hash value that can be
used as a sort of check sum uh and then
you can uh and then if the check sums
turn out to differ um you can figure out
exactly where uh those two pieces of
data differ. So that would that could be
used for security, right? Uh you could
try to figure out uh you could use this
mechanism to figure out um if your data
has been messed with. And so Merkel
trees are often discussed in this
context of authentication, right? To
make sure that uh that your data hasn't
been messed with.
Now in this paper, uh they're kind of
leaving aside that whole question of
authentication, right? They're talking
about replicas that are in an Amazon
data center. they're not untrusted,
right? So that so in this paper they're
only using Merkel trees for this uh for
for this um for the purpose of saving
bandwidth between replicates. So they're
not they're not worried about so much
about the case of data getting corrupted
uh by by some attacker, right? Which is
the context in which you often hear
Merkel trees discussed. Um they're they
were only worried about saving
bandwidth. So it turns out Merkel trees
are are useful for for solving both of
those problems.
Okay, so there's a couple more questions
uh in in chat here. Somebody asked how
do they decide uh how do they say which
of these values is more recent, right?
So yeah, so you can store a time stamp
on these elements. Uh you could store a
vector clock um and compare those. Um,
but you know, job one, right, is finding
out that replicas differ at all. Then
finding out how to resolve the conflict
is another question. And we talked about
about strategies for that. Maybe you
don't resolve the conflict. Maybe
replica 2 says, "Oh, I have five for y."
And replica one says, "Oh, okay. I guess
I'll store both four and five." And then
if the client wants to know what y is,
I'll give the client both. Um, so that's
that's an orthogonal problem, right?
this question of how do you resolve the
conflict? So, so Merkel trees help with
the first problem which is finding out
that there is a conflict at all.
So, one question that came up um when I
taught this course last year and I and I
drew this picture on the board um
somebody asked well in this case you
have XYZ Q on both of these replicas.
So, uh what if what if one replica had a
different set of keys? like how how
would the replicas know uh
how uh like what what what if what if a
replica has a different set of keys than
the other replicas then then how do you
construct these these Merkel trees?
So this is like the standard picture
that people usually draw when they talk
about Merkel trees. Um,
and so if if you if you were to Google
for Merkel trees and do do a Google
image search, you always always see this
thing that that looks like a binary
tree. So, but there's this great
question, right? How does this Merkel
tree thing work if the replicas don't
know about the same set of keys?
Um, so
in in the Dynamo paper, it seems like
the answer is
all the replicas know which key ranges
they're supposed to be responsible for.
Um, so they can just have an entry in
the Merkel tree for every key in the
range, whether or not there's actually a
value associated with that key. Um, and
these ranges are pretty big, right? So
you might want to try to use some
efficient uh representation of the tree
for the tree to be of tractable size. Um
but so that's that's one thing that you
could do. Um but but a more interesting
answer might be that instead of storing
the data in this binary tree um instead
you would use uh what's known as a
prefix tree or a try or whatever it is
that you choose to call it. Um so a a a
prefix tree uh is keyed on hashes of the
keys.
Don't confuse that with these hashes. So
these hashes are are hashing the values,
right? And that's the whole point,
right? That that we want to see if the
values differ between replicates. Um so
in a prefix tree, um you get this thing
where where you have hashes of keys and
then you can look up a key in the data
structure. um by its hash. Um so there's
two different if if that's what you were
doing um if you had a prefix tree and
you were also doing this thing of
hashing the data for quick comparison
between replicas, there's two different
kinds of hashes being talked about. This
took me a while to get my head around.
Um so the the resulting data structure
um is a prefix tree that's also doing
this thing where it's hashing the data.
Um, so you might call it a merkelized
prefix tree or my favorite, a merkellix
tree.
So
Merkel plus prefix tree
is known as a Merkel tree. Um,
so this is this is a term you might have
heard. Blockchain people talk about it a
lot. Um, but it's not just for
blockchain stuff. Um, despite what
blockchain people might have you
believe. Um, so my uh my former
colleague Graden Horror told me that
this Merkix tree uh was in fact the data
structure that he implemented uh when he
was implementing a version control
system called monotone um back in the
early 2000s. Um, and this is what he
used for synchronizing copies of
objects.
Um, so and he didn't even he just called
it a Merkel tree or he called it a
Merkel tree because it it didn't occur
to him that there was a version that
wasn't also a prefix tree, but Merkel
tree is the silly name that some people
use for that.
So that's that's kind of my answer to
this question of if replicas had
different set of keys and you didn't
have this ahead of time knowledge of who
was responsible for what key ranges then
you could use merllix trees and then you
would determine that a rep that replicas
have different sets of keys um by just
looking at the structure of the prefix
tree and then for keys that disagree on
value you could use um you you could you
could use the hashes of the values. That
doesn't seem to be what Dynamo actually
does, but um but it was for me it was it
it's it was worthwhile for me to learn
about this anyway. So I'm sharing it
with you as well.
Okay.
So let's do a quiz question.
Let's talk really briefly about last
time's quiz question.
So last time our question was just uh
what does it mean for a for replicated
storage system to be strongly
convergent? So the definition of strong
convergence is replicas that have
received the same set of updates have
equivalent state regardless of the order
in which those updates were received. So
it's a safety property.
And here is today's quiz question.
So, there was just a question uh on
Twitch about uh hash collisions.
So, sure. So, so what would happen if
you had a hash collision? Uh well, let's
say that uh you had a a crappy hash
function and the the hash of four and
the hash of five here ended up being the
same. Well, yeah, indeed. Then um then
this update might not make it to the
other replica, right? So this mechanism
is dependent on you having a good hash
function. Uh so
I suppose um you if if you wanted to
decrease your vulnerability to that um
then you could uh you could try having
having multiple
uh anti-entropy mechanisms uh using
different hash functions. Of course then
you have to store the results of those
different hash functions. Um, but I
think this uh, no, I I I think like a
standard good quality hash function
turned out to be good enough for their
needs. And they didn't care about it
being a cryptographically secure hash
function because uh, again, they weren't
concerned so much with security. They
weren't concerned with ensuring that uh,
that the data uh, didn't get uh
corrupted by an attacker on the way from
one replica to another. Instead, they
were just concerned with with uh, with
making sure that the replicas were up to
date.
Okay. So in the in the five minutes that
we have left uh I want to quickly touch
on one more concept uh which came up in
the paper
uh and which is very useful to know
about. Um so this is a concept of what's
called quorum consistency.
And we won't have time to discuss this
fully today. So we'll talk about it more
next time. Um but let's let's just touch
on it. So in primary backup replication
and chain replication uh clients would
only talk to particular nodes, right? In
primary backup the client only talk to
the primary and in chain replication uh
the client would talk to the head and
the tail uh the head for rights and the
tail for reads. But in Dynamo the client
can actually talk to any replica or all
of them. So no replica is playing a
distinguished role. Um so suppose we
have a client and three replicas
and the client is actually aware of the
identities of all these nodes. So
in some sense
the client kind of starts to resemble
the primary from primary backup
replication, right? Because the client
can go out and talk to all these nodes
and get responses from all of them.
But how many does it have to talk to?
So in quorum systems uh which is what
Dynamo is, uh this is actually something
that's configurable.
So
how many should I talk to?
So there there are three important
variables. So n is the number of
replicas
in this case three.
W
is the number of replicas that have to
acknowledge you
before you can consider a right
operation to have completed
also known as the right quorum
and r is the same thing for reads.
That's the number of replicas that have
to acknowledge you that uh before you
consider a read operation to have
completed
or the read quorum.
So W and R are both going to be at most
N, right? But they could be less than N.
So let's think about some different
combinations of W and R. Um let's
suppose that in this three replica
system, we set W to three. So three
replicas have to acknowledge a right.
And let's say that we set R to one. If
we did that, so if W were three
and R was one,
do you think that would give you strong
consistency?
Somebody says no.
Somebody else says yes.
Yeah. So it actually would um so if you
if you if three replicas need to
acknowledge a right before you consider
that right to have completed then if you
write to all three
then
if you do a read you know that you're
going to read that right.
So this is a very popular setting. Um
sometimes called write one
or excuse me read one
write alla.
So this actually does give you strong
consistency. Um
but
What's wrong with it? Well, it's not
fault tolerant in the sense that if a
node crashes or if there's a network
partition that separates a node uh some
nodes from the client, then the client
can't do any writes, right? Because the
client has to write to three before the
right is considered to have committed.
Um so this is not necessarily the best
setting for all situations.
Uh, we're out of time. So, we're going
to come back to this and we're going to
talk about it much more next time. I
will see you on Wednesday. Take care.